okay
we want to start with number 325
followed by 257.
oh that was quite a welcome are you sure
you're pressed
[Laughter]
hello
okay
hi Michelle congratulations right here
um I just want to say congratulations my
name is Talia Sager from the daily Bruin
um I just wanted to ask like what does
this win mean to you in terms of like
aging representation within the
entertainment industry and even just the
Asian representation on the screen in
terms of your role as Evelyn
this is actually a historical moment so
I really have to thank the academy
for acknowledging embracing diversity
and true representation I think this is
something that we have been working so
hard towards for a very long time and
tonight we freaking broke that God
ceiling
I converted out and shattered it
and we need this because there are so
many who have felt unseen unheard it's
not just the Asian Community this is for
the Asian Community but for anybody
who's been identified as a minority we
deserve to be heard we deserve to be
seen we deserve to have the equal
opportunities so we can have a seat at
the table that's all we are asking for
give us that opportunity let us prove we
are worth it
no
okay next up we have 257 followed by one
four four
hi Michelle straight ahead right here
which is straight
[Laughter]
to the left kind of oh there you are hi
Morgan morale from BuzzFeed
congratulations thank you okay I also
have a diversity question okay so being
a woman of color
um in any space but particularly in
Hollywood you can sometimes be made to
feel like other and that maybe you don't
belong in a certain role or even in a
certain room so I want to know have you
ever felt like taking a step back from
acting and because you stayed what
advice would you give to people who are
afraid to take up space
you should never be afraid if this is
your passion this is your love you have
to stand up for yourself and for what
you believe in and for what you want to
do and I think that is what it is I'm
still here today finally after 40 years
I I get this it just goes to show we
will we will win the battle and that's
what we're doing so don't give up never
give up because once you give up then
it's a loss that's total loss right so
yes don't let anybody put you in a box
don't let anybody say oh you're past
your Prime blah blah blah blah blah blah
no because we are proud We Believe In
what we do we love what we do so light
that fire in your soul and stay on the
path believe Dare To Dream because if
you don't dream then it's impossible but
nothing is impossible look at me I'm
here
so thank you
okay next we have 144 followed by
197. hey Michelle I'm Raymond Lowe from
the Philippines for the Philippine Star
um so yesterday was exactly a year ago
when everything everywhere all at once
premiered at South by Southwest right
can you take us back to that day last
year and refer to that day to how you
are feeling today with all the success
today
it's been quite a marathon hasn't it
to be honest when we did South by
Southwest that was the first time when
everybody why do we make movies for the
cinema that we want a collective
experience where we want to enjoy share
that laughter cry crying or whatever it
is together and that is what the magic
of being in the at the movies at South
by Southwest it was a the first actual
um
not streaming not virtual festival and
we were so blessed that
everyone came and we were blown away
because you know you give your heart and
soul to a movie but there is never any
guarantee how when you put it up in the
sky please don't fall flat on your face
right and please go oh
and I swear to God is you all of you
because you made it interesting you made
it wild and wacky to people who hadn't
had an opportunity to watch it you made
it so interesting they had to come to
the cinemas to watch this what crazy
wacky movie are we talking about because
you didn't want to be left out of the
conversation so in that way thank you to
all of you you propelled our little gem
of a film yes we had a huge beating
heart but you propelled us to the skies
and the world embraced us so I thank you
from the bottom of my heart because all
of you had a place you had something to
do with that and I am really really
grateful because this movie has helped
in some healing process this movie had
has helped in communication this movie
has helped to Open Hearts between
families whether it's husband and wife
friends
daughters and Mothers Daughters and
fathers but just simply family
and we never give up on each other so I
thank all of you for helping us do that
okay next up we have 197 followed by
final question 247. oh I'm final okay uh
American violations uh I'm from War
Journal so would you say something in
Chinese uh to Asian community in
Cantonese or Mandarin um
all the Asian communities we are seen we
are heard and we have a seat at the
table so I am so grateful eternally
grateful to all of you thank you thank
you
I know my Cantonese is actually not very
good but none of you know that
all right 247 last question
hi
the mouth oh a microphone this is very
helpful should I repeat okay I'm just
going to repeat okay hi I am Mia
levicino with letterboxed and you keep
mentioning how important mothers are in
your speeches and my mom has told me
that you're hero and now you're a hero
to you know all these little boys and
girls that look like us and I'm curious
um what is something that your mother
told you or gave you that you've carried
with you through this journey I think
mothers are very important to all of us
because if without for them none of us
would be sitting in this room to start
off with but I what the most important
thing is my mother has always
um
instilled in me confidence uh taught me
about love
taught me about kindness and compassion
I'm not very very good at that at times
and actually the recent thing that she
asked me to do is don't wear pants to
the Oscar
I think what mothers do is they're
constantly reminding you to be better
and they do it with love and they do it
because they really want you to be
better so you have more opportunities
and you will have a better life and that
for them is their ultimate goal
thank you so much thank you wonderful
thank you so much and congratulations
Michelle yo
all right